el propio presidente de ucrania ce lens
que ha asegurado que había hasta 1000
personas en ese centro comercial que ha
sido atacado en la ciudad de crimen
chuck en la región de poltava que está a
más de 100 kilómetros del frente de
batalla por lo que no ha sido artillería
lo que ha impactado contra el centro
comercial sino un misil de medio y largo
alcance los bomberos están intentando
apagar el fuego el número de heridos y
de fallecidos está aumentando y es
bastante probable que a estas horas
hubiera bastante gente porque es un
horario en el que las familias y los
ciudadanos que viven en ucrania utilizan
para comprar comida y productos de
primera necesidad la situación está
empeorando en todo el país en el este y
no solo en el donbass también en heart
kit que hace frontera comportaba de
hecho portaba se utiliza es una ciudad
que utilizan en muchos ciudadanos para
refugiarse de los ataques que se están
produciendo aquí en kharkiv no sé si
alcanzan a ver pero en los últimos días
esta ciudad está rodeada de columnas de
humo por los continuos ataques que
recibe por el flanco norte en la
frontera con rusia pero también por el
sur porque él russo está avanzando no
solo en el donbass sino también aquí en
jarquín y se teme que mañana día feriado
en ucrania por el día de la constitución
aumente el número de ataques por eso las
autoridades han pedido a los ciudadanos
que por favor no acudan a lugares donde
se concentren en muchas personas para
poder para evitar así ser objetivos de
ataques y de bombardeos como lo que ha
ocurrido hoy en ese centro comercial en
crema ancha